[Music]
they have hidden in our midst for
centuries a strange race of genetically
enhanced beings known as the Inhumans
the result of an ancient experiment
forged on the plains of prehistory they
have evolved in seclusion until now
a bomb ignites spreading the catalytic
energies of the Terrigen mists
the fall of a kingdom gives rise to an
army as across the globe countless
thousands are revealed as Inhumans
now they are among us their powers are
raw and untested and as the pandemic
continues to spread the heroes of Earth
must face the rise of the original
superhuman race witness the Marvel
Universe plunge into
in humanity these Inhumans even exist
not anymore
[Music]
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel just
announced that they're developing a
spin-off TV series for agents of shield
that might even debut by this fall so
I'll explain what they said how it's
supposed to work and what I think those
TV shows are gonna turn into what they
said is is that the spin-off show will
draw from material developed in the back
half of agents of shield season 2 so all
this stuff that's happening with the
Inhumans is probably what's going to
lead up into the spin-off that doesn't
mean it's exclusively going to be an
inhuman show but but don't be surprised
if they announced the title is Inhumans
I mean talk about brand awareness in the
simplest of terms ABC and Marvel are
just doing the exact same thing that era
did when they spun off the flash what
happened is is they had Barry Allen they
brought him on in like a special
two-part episode and then use that is
like a litmus test to show the network
to say that hey we want to develop a
spin-off show the network liked it so
much they said okay go ahead and do a
separate pilot the rest is history the
flash ended up being CW's biggest hit of
all time Marvel wants to exploit more of
their IP ABC wants more popular shows so
naturally they're just gonna try and
mind like the most interesting things
that they can right now that's Inhumans
just you know big group from the comics
that hasn't been explored a lot on TV in
the movies what about timing you know
when is this show supposed to air what
what they've said so far is that the
plan is is that they would premiere it
in the fall as soon as the fall that
doesn't mean that I'll end up happening
they might end up pushing it but for all
intents and purposes just expect it to
air alongside a since a shield in the
fall just like the flash and arrow air
on different nights I know a lot of you
are asking what does this mean about
agent Carter because agent Carter was
like their other show they haven't said
anything about it but they just made all
these big plans for another spin-off
show it doesn't mean that it's canceled
agent Carter is still like unofficially
getting a season two typically May is
when networks make their final decisions
about which new shows they're picking up
and which shows that are cancelling one
of the issues I think the agent Carter
runs into is that it's more about
characters and less about spectacle and
and typically what brings in like big
eyeballs like all across the world is
the spectacle part the show itself is
amazing agent Carter is great but agents
of shield on the other side of that coin
provides more opportunities for big
spectacles and really personal character
moments the same thing happened with
arrow whenever they first started making
that show it was supposed to be really
dark and gritty nose
for powers so like the spectacled level
was turned way way down cut to a couple
years later Barry Allen super-powered
individuals debuts on TV everyone loves
it in networks realized oh we can do
these crazy super powers and people will
watch it people really enjoy this so I
feel like this is Marvel and ABC
responding to people wanting to see you
know powers versus powers as opposed to
regulars versus powers what about the
cast though I know everyone's asking
like does that mean the characters from
agents of shield will transition to the
new show no I think it'll be just like
arrow in the flash the agents of shield
cast will stay on Asian to shield
what'll happen is is they'll bring in
like a new big character that they think
can lead the spin-off show and then
they'll build that show around them then
you'll have characters like Skye
Inhumans with powers that can jump back
and forth between shows and obviously
Phil Coulson is always gonna jump back
and forth between all the shows and all
the movies there's even a rumor that
Coulson is gonna be the one on the
Netflix shows to assemble the defenders
to like go to daredevil Jessica Jones
Luke Cage iron fist and say hey I'm
putting a team together so if you
haven't been watching them I'd recommend
you check out Aaron the flash just to
see how the characters bounced back and
forth between those shows because I
think Marvel and ABC you're gonna do the
exact same thing of all the possible
names that they could give the spin-off
show there's secret warriors and
Inhumans at the top of the list
it just it depends on how on the nose
they want to be because there's gonna be
an Inhumans movie so I don't know
necessarily that they want a movie with
the same name as a TV show although
there is a flash TV show and there's
gonna be a flash movie it really just
depends on how they want to portray all
these inhuman people and whether or not
they're gonna do something like terrigen
bomb and introduce a whole bunch of new
Inhumans that would have to come after
an event on the magnitude of shield
coming down during Winter Soldier we
really have no idea what Marvel is gonna
do to develop Inhumans inside the movie
universe before the Inhumans movie we've
only seen him on TV so far they could
new terrigen bomb or they could just
like slowly tease them out if you're not
familiar with the Terrigen bomb a couple
years ago in the comics Black Bolt
dropped a Terrigen bomb on the earth
creating thousands and thousands of new
Inhumans all at the same time that was
actually what led to the creation of the
new Kamala Khan Miss Marvel wouldn't
that be awesome if she were on the
spin-off show that would be badass so
here's my big question for you guys who
do you want to see on this new spinoff
and do you think that they're gonna call
it in humans I'll say at the top of my
list what I'd really like to see is a
version of runaways
within humans like like they're pushing
in humans so hard right now that they
have to be involved in some way but
runaways just feels like a really fun
show something they can use to balance
out the seriousness that you see on
shield every week there is a lot of
funny stuff on shield but it is a very
dark show so I think it'd be fun if like
they had their version of the flash show
there could be about powers versus
powers and have a little bit more fun
with itself in related news I know
everyone's asking when order the
daredevil episode it's gonna drop so
midnight tonight as I'm posting this
video on Thursday midnight Thursday
Pacific time is when everything is
coming what I'll probably do is post my
first spoilery Easter Egg video by like
early Friday sometime so be sure to
subscribe to get that don't worry if you
don't get Netflix you can't get Netflix
eventually they will release the show on
DVD but really I would recommend doing
anything you can to watch it as soon as
possible
do not wait it is so much fun you guys
have no idea I'm also working on a game
of Thrones super recap from like
everything from season 1 to season 4 for
people that aren't caught up so try and
post that tonight so lots of daredevil
lots of Game of Thrones coming this
weekend it's gonna be so much fun
I hope you guys got some extra sleep
this week well you guys wait for all
that stuff to drop in case you haven't
seen it you can click here for my
non-spoilery review of the first couple
of episodes of daredevil Thor no
spoilers in there and you can click here
for all my Game of Thrones Season 5
videos thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys in a little bit
you